hi dog walker and Amy's brother and this
is sibling rivalry protect our people
it's your destiny what you're searching
for in here hiccup is back with his
Dragon Riders except this time it's not
as much How to Train Your Dragon as how
to ignite a family reunion as we have
his mother in this one and his father is
back and they're off to stop this evil
IRL are suspicious you see that a
trailer uh and they're off to stop this
evil villain oh of course wants to take
over the world in I'll to Train Your
Dragon 2 it's kind of how to retrain
your dread yeah yeah uh so of course we
this is another sequel you know we can't
talk about a sequel reboot remake
anything without talking about what we
thought the first one um I haven't read
any of the book - have you read any of
them oh yeah I didn't know it was a book
until I saw the credits to this I can't
forget was - um so uh but it take em
quick when we thought the first one uh
the first one by most accounts I should
not worry because stories like this
drive me nuts that don't judge a book by
it's cover the prejudice parental figure
who just won't listen to reason and the
son who has to keep a secret and the
lime juice the morals no no no I hear
also been hammered in and we've seen
done a million times and don't add that
much new but for some reason the first
one really worked and I think it's or I
really enjoyed a day away and I think
it's the atmosphere I think it's the
painting I think it's the passion of it
uh the it's still the greatest 3d movie
I've ever seen I saw that IMAX in 3d it
was unbelievable um and I think all that
passion everything really made the the
characters in the story somehow work I
surprisingly really enjoyed it I would
you think of it I you know my wife and I
saw it on a lark we were uh yeah I know
interested see watching Melissa she was
watching her university play in the NCAA
tournament or something I think
were trying to get into the tournament
and they lost in a final for a Big Ten
game with it whatever was they've lost
and it was a bad loss it was like just
an embarrassing they should've lost and
she was pissed I mean was intimately
pissed my wife is a hardcore sports fan
one comes to college sports she's okay
I'm like you know the professional woman
yeah I don't know yeah anyway so she's
like that we were in Michigan at the
time and she's like I gotta go I gotta
leave I have to get out of this house I
cannot take this any longer I have to
let's see a movie and I'm like well I
don't really know what's out I mean this
was still I think it was like late
spring or something it's like I I don't
know what's out I don't care I just
won't see any movie so we just showed up
at the cinema like a seven or eight ish
and we were just looking at it there was
like nothing out and there is How to
Train Your Dragon and I remembered the
ads and I thought oh that looks terrible
it just looks like a bad dream works
movie I'm like not fishtail bad but just
a bad and I'm like but you know what I'm
like she's pissed off and and I got
nothing better to do so we'll see that
it's a kids movie at least it's not
gonna hopefully like offend us too much
so we saw it in 3d we put on our 3d
glass they didn't leave it fun and yeah
by the end of it I'm like what the
yeah what's the best 3d movie I have
ever seen in my life I mean it was on
par with Avatar I think it's better than
I haven't yeah and I'm like and we both
kept staring at each other it's like who
would have thought how to train a dragon
would be the best 3d movie we've ever
seen like cuz I thought it would have
been one of those things with the 3ds
just tossed in at the last second and it
would just be okay but now it was really
good I loved the story I really liked it
was the biggest surprise of that year
and the second it came out on blu-ray
like we bought it I'm like this movie's
amazing so DreamWorks has this habit of
taking stuff that should suck and making
it really good um which I'm really
impressed I bet they did this stuff a
hand-drawn story of Moses and it was
really good it's like who would have
thought kung fu panda come from
although the one animal - yeah amazing
so now we have the we have the sequel
here um there's a cliff note version it
is better than the first uh and it's
better than the first because it takes
advantage of what it can do with it now
they can ride dragons by the end of this
well they do they explore they go find
new worlds they go find new dragons if
they find new characters and the
characters grow up it's an anime film
where the kids are not just kid they
actually grow older uh and they quit
star trek into darkness should have been
that I'm thinking about it's like the
explore new worlds just new characters
the character we're just gonna set
everything backwards a little bit so you
can start learning it all again it's Ino
they really go above and beyond they
they age the character yeah they
actually get older really into yeah that
was really interesting and they did it
believable like I'm like okay I actually
think this is the same guy only he's
aged now he's a little more maturity the
who does that you know we just don't see
it yeah well especially in a kids anime
a film where you can keep the kids
younger and I think most these people
are doing voices or so I have these
voices naturally so they don't need to
make them older to account for the voice
but they made an older because they're
like this time has passed they're gonna
grow up so you know and they're gonna
add new responsibilities and they're
gonna have new things to tackle and
that's great and that's new uh and it
comes across mother played by Cate
Blanchett uh who is wonderful and it's
very P yeah like this new age dragon
hippie who's like gone a little too
native she's like all Jane Goodall with
the chimps or something and she's like
yes I can feel it all over movements are
like very dragon like it's bizarre but
but it was ring yeah it's an interesting
character it's not just like well I'm
the parent and neither of these parents
are just the parent even the father who
comes so easily just been v I'm never
gonna listen and that did they somehow
made that interest and the relationship
with his mother is so great and it just
kept hammering and I was like when do we
see that in an animated film how many
animated mothers have we ever got well
especially among
so it's always a father-son a
father-daughter tale but yeah a
mother-son tale like yeah we're starting
to see more another daughter and Boyle
Sister Sister uh go back to like maybe
like something like Bambi Nick and they
were animals so um but yeah so at the
much more flying scenes in this one and
they all look beautiful we sadly we saw
this on the whatever Thursday night they
didn't have it in IMAX they do now which
I might I might have to go see it again
because I'm just getting out that I
might I don't feel cheated not seeing it
I don't know but the IMAX a 3d for the
first film was like a game-changer to me
like that's what I didn't have and
that's what avatar like what everyone
said about avatar that was my avatar
that was my oh my god this is like
making me look at film totally different
and with the flying scenes in this one
now I'm really curious if like it's even
better because there are so many in this
um so so you got uh that there's really
great really enjoyable feel I mean
really like I'm watching it's like man
this is like one of the best of the year
and then you get to the second half
where the villain comes in and it's
still good but it's like okay now this
is the first film again like this is the
really boring villain you kind of know
scene by seeing what's going to happen
the sort of elements about like
controlling the train guitaring no not
but it's like as a nitpicker don't you
know it is still uh put mumbler you know
it's still good with the exception the
villain I think the villainy is
annoyingly dull cuz you could have made
this a really fun interesting villain
but he's the traditional wah wah ha ha
ha he's all that stuff the only thing I
will say is you could have fleshed out
his backstory more because they were
flashbacking like two or three times I'm
like walking why we flash back to his
origin story they just show him coming
into me leg on her feet dragoons
yeah energy even that was a little
intimidating us it's like older building
him up okay let's see and he's just
every other villain you've seen I use
that here's the thing though it didn't
really bother me because we actually got
a villain what was the villain of the
visit oh yeah I'm the evil dragon that
we got a kill I guess cuz he's
commanding the other like well I'll say
this too that is explained much better
in this film to the whole alpha dragon
thing that's fine I like the fed then
now we're getting some explanation for
what happened the first one but I'm just
kind of like why can you just told us at
in the first fifth I agree no I like I
said even though I loved the first film
it does have problems yes for me the
climax was the weakness in the first
film because in this film they fixed it
and this one he's all about like we
gotta do diplomacy and and like I can
convince him I changed you dad I can
convince this villain you know this were
in like his final line about like we're
a village of peace peace peace and like
they were hammering that in as well in
the first one but it was a mixed message
cuz it's just like no dragons and humans
can get along we can live in peace so
what we got to do kill that drag like
wait a second know what I like about
this one too is that he tries diplomacy
and he's very eager about travel on the
scene what I like watching is I'm saying
myself I don't know this will work or
not I again I was not sure where this
was going like tonight films like that
but that's where it is the one thing cuz
this was one problem Kung Fu Panda 2
didn't have Kung Fu Panda 2 the villain
was a villain and creepy and
intimidating front peacock even yeah and
there was some sympathy there you felt
like maybe there's a chance that somehow
PO would be able to convince him they
didn't do that but I felt like it was
more open and in this one there wasn't a
lot of sympathy with him we didn't
really know his backstory anything about
Ori Mia we just know he was attacked by
a dragon at one point he lost his arm
well join the club everyone else in this
world has yeah and he's just kind of a
jerk and it's like men you could have
had very interesting villain with this
and there's a character I don't think
I'm giving anything away with this
because they make it very obvious in the
first five minutes the first
conversation hiccup has you know a
character it's gonna get acted off and I
won't say who it is but when it finally
happens it's I've never seen myself
don't go that direction please because I
really like I like you going the
direction where I don't know where it's
going
cuz this film
to doing that even though I like the
first one you can tell scene by scene
where was going and I like that I
couldn't tell what George was gonna take
and then when he get to the second half
it's like oh it's the by-the-numbers now
okay but it's still it's done well the
action is still great the fly is still
great I still like the Cure it's all
about the execution I don't care if a
story's predictable if it's executed
really really well I get better movies
I've seen with no twist in it everything
you know that's gonna happen happens
exactly like you predict but it's really
fun to watch but but with that said what
in this in my opinion I think this could
have been like one of the great fantasy
films like this could have been like the
Dark Knight of like fantasy films or
something if they had a good villain if
a villain was really good at really
intriguing instead I feel like we got
Batman Begins where the first amp is
really inspiring really new oh my god
this is changing everything then the
second half is very by-the-numbers
you're just nitpicking it's not that
it's not that bad no it's still the the
way they the storyboarding in this movie
and the use of music any animation no
lighting as well in the lighting in the
camera angles it it made the villain
even though there wasn't a whole lot
there he still was intimidating and was
quite the presence like I thought the
build-up was good I thought he was
interesting yeah he needed to be fleshed
out more but again we actually got
something we got a big dragon and in the
first one that just kind of Santa ran
like it there was just nothing there
I'll take this guy in what else I'm
missing the bummer view I say you know
for a film call a film series called How
to Train Your Dragon we don't see how he
trains that giant alpha dragon which is
I think a pretty legit question where
it's like all the our dragons are at
least people sighs he could survive say
how did he train that thing that's like
the size of 5 million Sears towers or
whatever to you know obey Him maybe we
never there's no magic I don't know no
there are some issues but the other
thing is I don't know how bound by the
book they're I mean I have no idea
that's what yeah but like the thing is
they even explain it more the thing that
happens in the middle that you're
complaining about
I don't did that happen in the book I
have no idea why even if it did
I I get this book to move each a you can
change stuff it was still in the here's
the thing it was emotionally affecting
if a lessor director or a lessor group
or story artist had done this I would
probably just be like right with you
like a thought coming Rubick deprived
now we gonna say but I it upset me it
was a really good seaman for a kid so
much dark hmm like really does it the
way they do it like the the
quote-unquote execution no pun intended
um and who they used to do it yeah I
think like you say especially for kids
film it's kind of messed off well and
there's a I mean the whole thing is a
metaphor for how we treat animals and
this whole thing about like you know
dragons aren't born bad you know it's
the people you know the people with you
know it's same way with animals
you know you train a dog to kill that's
what a dog is gonna do and the same
thing happens in this movie and when his
own dragon just starts turning on him
I'm like this is legitimately creepy and
like upsetting this is kind of Old
Yeller it was very old yellowish
territory because you've grown to like
these too you know and the connection
they have and the dragon is sort of this
pet bed it's just like to see your pet
turn on you like that I was like oh my
god like I'm an adult and I'm like this
is creeping me out and you know I can't
imagine we saw it with very few kids
there because it was a late night
showing but I can't wait until like the
weekend with all the kids in your tears
ha ha ha mmm yummy yeah cuz I'm just
like duh I'm just waiting for it because
I know there's gonna be kids in the
audience just whipping their over
that well but these films are all even
the first one does like they are quote
unquote kids films but there is this
aggression to it uh there is something
very aggressive it is it is kind of
Viking times and yes they can talk a
little modern and that we're following
the kids and stuff but I mean there's
like people will lose limbs you know and
stuff like that
arrested no I think what sells the movie
though is the energy yeah it's not only
aggressive but there's just an energy to
every scene there's very few scenes
where I'm like okay getting kind of
bored it just it knows how to just milk
the ability to fly and have all of these
dragons running around and the battles
those epic battles Michael Bay should
take notes on how to film a battle
because the last 20 minutes of this
movie is spectacular it's as good as
anything in Godzilla I was actually
gonna say I actually felt more are you
talking about the kind of middle battle
or the very very last battle oh I'm not
making more kind of the middle okay the
minute I'm sorry that matters to this
two baths also comes around my head no
that's also come from my head - I felt
the middle battle more than overshadow
the the file one which it's not always a
problem honestly there's a long ways
with the bigger battles and then get
Dark Knight the bigger battles in the
middle um so it doesn't bother me too
much but yeah there's still there's one
or two things that aren't that clear MA
you know like with the end - with sort
of again without giving away too much
serve all the dragons turning as tenants
are like wait a minute
Oh what I don't care you know cause like
he said I'm a Beaujolais no no that made
total sense see he's got the ability to
do that he explained that in the moment
we probably when you got up and hit the
restaurant no oh maybe I did miss that
you're with you with your bladder the
size of a thimble he explained how his
whole sword weapon works and how have
you activated it releases this sort of
gas and he's able to help get again no
no no no none unless I'm a man I'm
talking about with the alpha dragon and
toothless and how all the dragons you
know what happens at the end there I'm
sort of no no no I totally got that it's
toothless toothless fought that thing
like a cornered cat no no I got that
everyone sort to it but it's like but
there's instinct in like Pride and we're
gonna follow this and then there's
hypnotism that sort of the Dragon is
doing to which it like like I said I'm
not oh my god heaven forbid there's
magic no no that's
is that made super clear but like I said
it's totally quick no no I I agree it's
nitpicking like there's little stuff
like that until they explain the whole
alpha dragon concept like this made much
more sense no interest movie is a weight
loss um like soup is a queen dragon is
just like aliens how does this work well
I agree I do think it does explain that
like I said this is nitpicking stuff but
I'm just saying that there are small
things here there even the kids voice
you know sometimes get a little grating
once alright now that I told me yeah I
for the most part I'm okay with it but
if I have one nitpick in this movie and
only one I think it's even more so than
the first one a very talky movie in
certain points there are these long
speeches where I feel like you could
have just had a line of dialogue or to
something more pointed in instead he
goes on this long speech about how we've
got to come together and get in peace
and it just goes on and on and on and
you don't understand data and his voice
just after a while just you know it gets
in your ear India chews it up you know
it is surprising those didn't bother me
that much even though I agree with you
that a lot of it could have been made
shorter but didn't bother me that much
because I think this world is so
comfortable with itself and so wants to
live with itself it it is so enjoyable
that I didn't mind when they would just
sit down and just talk and just soak up
the environment has no mind when they
just talk or soak up the environment I
mind when literally he practically
stands on a soapbox or says the exact
same thing he says the exact same thing
literally a paragraph that is
constructed entirely of sentences where
he's repeating himself yeah like that's
the issue I don't like no I like the
slow moments I like the time he had
spent with his mother investigating the
sort of lair of the Dragons they find in
this net I like soaking up the
environment I you know it is a normally
person who's not like get back to the
action but if you're giving a speech and
I start like going into a snorer phase
or just like
you know at that point your speech is
too long or it's too wordy or tall I say
at the end like you know I I don't think
we're giving anything away the good
people win you know but when they're
sort of boiler yeah well when they're
sort of talking to the bad guy and he's
sort of reiterating the message I'm
thinking yeah we got it so we know oh
yeah something something Dragon's
something something living together yes
like we anyone can change yeah and it's
a fine moral I have no problem with the
moral I have no problem if it does sound
overused or cliche it's just stop
telling us we got it like um just do it
no I see everything in this movie even
though I've can't talk about this I get
nothing in this movie is anything less
than the first it sort of starts with
the first it's like everything is as
good as the first at least and really
only goes off yeah it only goes up um so
yeah I really enjoyed it
um I think place I definitely joy the
first half more than the second but it's
still like I said nothing nothing is
anything less than its predecessor and
that is what a good sequel should do it
should go above and beyond what the
previous one day should introduce new
things by you know but also allowing you
to get familiar with what you liked in
the first one and take it in new
directions and yeah I I greatly enjoyed
it I think the 3d is just as good and
there's much more of the flying scenes
and I probably won't go see it again an
IMAX just so I can see it again IMAX cuz
I guess that that was a big game-changer
for the first one for me how sad is it
that I want to see this one again versus
almost anything coming out the rest of
summer oh you know what I want to that
Book of Life movie that's the ones
coming on it up that's coming on the
whole summer yeah you're right so ya
know somebody lock clusters I'm watch
Ellison summer yeah I kind of want to
see guardians of the galaxy but like I'm
like thinking about all the things
coming out and I'm like this damn kids
movies probably one of the best things
I've seen all year so far like I don't
know if it's gonna get much better than
this I mean I hope it does cuz I was one
things to be better but well kids movies
now we uh I was talking to Brad
he's doing a lot more of the sort of the
he'd always send off other people to go
see the bad kids films and stuff so this
year he's saying like I'll okay I'll
open up and see the kids felt like he
was telling me it's like it's actually
kept it secret cuz all the good fills
this year are probably gonna be the kids
faster and he's really right the kids on
its now going through are putting so
much more money and time and effort and
they're acting more adult than a lot of
the adult films and you know the pg-13 s
and the ARS and stuff and I think a lot
is because there is just more
possibility with the kids films you can
introduce these ideas like you know
whatever magic and flying around on
dragons and it doesn't have to make
sense how they always can hold onto them
without flying off and stuff like that
you can just sort of accept it and the
possibilities you know without more of
those limitations I think are made
stronger
well the steps in the slate had an
editorial like a week ago about how oh
well adults who read young adult fiction
should be ashamed and they should hide
in the closet and then they shouldn't
you know they can read it if they wanted
but I'm sure that was like a shitstorm
as a shame first off shut up nobody
likes you and second that was exactly
there was like everybody came out
against this I mean yeah it was even be
yeah it was nobody Nazis and communists
al Qaeda maybe like but it the are the
counter argument against it that was one
things ever saying is that kids stories
or stories of young adults are allowed
to get wildly inventive in ways that
adult stories aren't I'm just gonna say
it this film is more adult than most
summer blockbusters i see- sure you it's
gonna be more adult than like what our
transformer for which is you want you
want a kid's film but yeah you have
apparently for a dull yeah you're not a
kid's film that's meant for
four-year-olds transformers that is the
mindset yeah except when you nose for it
big breasted you know ever them and like
violins and sex and stuff they're man
times they're meant for 13 year olds you
don't want to grow up yeah
like but this film is more adult than
any of that and anyone
shame among you know right now no and
anyone can see it it is an interesting
time like I said where it's just like
there is it but I think it's such a good
thing uh that rather than going to what
we need to go to the adult films to get
anything good no cuz it used to be no
good kids films no good anime if else I
mean nobody even tried with them it's
like here's our garbage just to say we
did a kid film and that was it but now
they're really trying and they're trying
to get them really adult and he did at
Disney but they were the only game in
town but even though they went through
you know sort of a lull for a while
until uh you know babies aren't doing at
all because he died and then the second
loss gateway sighs no yeah no no I mean
every comfortable it's ours in the wall
right now like every company goes
through walls I don't think that I want
to tell Pixar I see how you do sequels
yeah please
Kung Fu Panda and a betrayal oh yeah
this is how you do know the cruelest
joke wait that's a Toy Story those are
good the cruelest joke was sitting
through that planes ad like right before
the satis I think that's Disney outfit
that's fit yeah though to be fair
actually I was looking I was like well
it still looks better than cars two
three if I have a third one coming
that's right but ya know I just go see
it yeah I think it's you know we're at a
time now where we kind of knew this
years ago when Disney was at the top of
its game about you know the snow and all
this stuff that you know age just
because you're making something for a
certain age doesn't mean you have to
dumb it down or it can't be good or it
can't be brilliant or all this ticketing
audience really seriously to the point
that again I can't wait for some of the
kids to start choking you know and did
Disney knew this I think they still know
it and other you know movies and studios
are catching on to it and they're trying
to change and they're trying to adapt to
it and I think it's great I think it's
wonderful and they're getting
artistically more free like I said I
think this uh this book of life that we
saw before I even see it straight before
a check this out it looks unbelievable
uh and they're just the lego movie you
know they're just expanding with what
they can do and having romo to your life
as well something from a Latin American
perspective yeah Emily
and so much culture in it and wonderful
designs and it like I said it's not just
a Oh we'll just throw it in from the you
know Latino promise I know you can tell
that's right a lot of effort in it and I
love that I know people always complain
about how much you know Oh movies these
days blah blah blah you didn't grow up
with the dark times that we did okay you
didn't grow up when CG was just
discovered and then that was the
attraction and it was nothing else you
know and there was no story no plot no
character it was just here some cool so
you got the and of course you got the
direct-to-dvd Disney sequels yeah I'm a
that I think girls are finally died out
it's all Tinkerbell and but it's
but I think the concept of like Bambi
seven is yeah that sings yeah go on
um but ya know cuz there and I talk
about you so I'm just talking about
films in general I think I want to say
from kind of like a little before
Godzilla on you know where we got
nothing but the Armageddon's and the you
know the disaster film era where anytime
so it just has to film okay no yeah
Dante's Peak deep in Faye it's like okay
these are all gonna suck and you just
knew it going in and it's like that's
all you got you just went to a movie
knowing it's gonna suck but what can you
do you want to see a movie and we were
kind of held hostage forever you'll now
we're gonna expand it got some more good
stuff but it not everything's change I
mean every year we get a Michael Bay
film oh no no but which is no dinner
than ever you're getting a Roland
Emmerich no no there used to be nothing
but those films though I mean and like I
said kiss entertainment with the
exceptions are who could put out a film
a year it was nothing it was deaf see
that that's what I'm trying to tell you
though that is the natural law that
happens in every company why because
Disney was hitting a wall DreamWorks was
just trying to kick itself off the
Groupon saying that there was also a
wall just in movies in general because
people for whatever reason they're just
like I just want see blow up
because we discovered CG and we like and
we want to see more of it and then
finally we got sicker than we ever got
the story and plot again I thought oh by
around 2001 2002 we start getting Lord
of the Rings we've got the x-men yes no
easy no exactly that's why this is sure
low low you said God
that was 1998 so you're talking about a
three year wall uh I say more like close
to five years that mask of zorro the
same year that's the one man that was
the one that everyone's like this is the
one movie that's actually a good action
film that's not just effects and
explosions but there was a good five
years of like nothing I need just maybe
I'll film a year would be good it's like
the worst that was always much bigger
than the best that just happens no no no
it is no no what I'm saying is that I I
know it happens I'm saying that you know
for all the people still going in
nothing good summer blockbusters and
it's like you didn't go through that
piece of cg rule everything they
might have done that was only 15 years
ago well the people are talking about
well then you don't appreciate what you
got right now cuz this is a good movie
like a movie was a good movie the
companies are there's a lot of good
animated films and there's you know even
some good wide well okay I'll give you
this the one difference is you're right
when that wall hit
it was a double whammy of there wasn't a
lot of really good blockbusters coming
out during that time but also Disney
died yeah Disney died you bet you make
some antenna robbed yeah that's what I'm
looking for a man arriving yeah yeah
Disney had died dreamworks is still just
getting off the ground so yeah there
you're right there wasn't an alternative
yeah i mean i mean not now there kind of
is because at least they're putting
effort into these animate anything Pixar
I mean they had Toy Story but bug's life
is cute I don't think that's a great
fall I mean is a movie a year it's like
you get to look forward to a movie a
year it's like no now we got there's
several good movies I can say came out
this yeah they're not all great and
they're not all fantastic but you know I
do feel like I've been on a lucky streak
cuz I didn't hate guns in what like some
people did I enjoyed x-men first class
the Captain America
coyote spider Man 2 head issues but it
still was better than spider-man 3 I'll
give it that at least and this one was
really good we had the lego movie yeah
it's actually I mean we're really
physically was here so far yeah I mean
so yeah that's why I'm saying so um yeah
I I really enjoyed this if you liked the
first one you're almost destined to like
this one too
um like I said it's it still got some
issues but let's just bring your plugs
whenever he starts speechify like a car
and that and yeah the guy if like I said
it's it's not perfect but the stuff
that's good is so good and if you can
see the 3d and IMAX definitely see it in
3d and IMAX because it's a it's
definitely very very good and very
enjoyable so um we need to live in peace
ba and